صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير نادين اهلا
وسهلا بكم معه ويعني انا من اعرق الاماكن
في سلطنه عمان وتحديدا العاصمه مسقط سوق
مطرح هذا المكان الذي يعود عمره لاكثر من
200 عام روائح البخور واللبان وايضا
الاجواء الجميله والسياح من كل اقطاب
الارض ياتون الى هذا المكان الذي يعتبر من
اكثر الاماكن حيويه في العاصمه العمانيه
سابع زميلي وليد يتجول في هذا السوق سهام
نادين ونتكلم اكثر عن تفاصيل هذا المكان
العريق يعني سوق مطرح طبعا يقع مقابل
ميناء سلطان هذا الميناء القديم ايضا الذي
اسس في السبعينات ميلاديه لكن تحول الان
الى ميناء سياحي
وايضا يعتبر هذا السوق كان وجه رئيسيه
للقوافل التي تاتي من جميع انحاء العالم
لقربه من
لذلك همم سمي مطرح لانه كانت تطرح فيه
البضائع بحسب تفسير بعض المؤرخين هذا
السوق سهام ونادين يعني شاهد حقيقي على
الكلاسيكيه في الاسواق الشعبيه وايضا يبين
الصوره الذهنيه اذا ما صحت تعبير عن
الفسيفساء الاجتماعي هنا في عمان وايضا
المعالم العمرانيه للاسواق الشعبيه يعني
في هذا المكان نستطيع ان نعايش جميع
التفاصيل الخاصه بالثقافه العمانيه
الثقافه العريقه
التي يعني تنغمس في الجمال والتفاصيل
والالوان والبهارات المشغولات اليدويه
الملابس البخور سوق جميل جدا ومدهش واللفه
انتباهي ايضا كثره السياحه حقيقه ربما مع
ايضا كاس العالم
ووجوده في قطر القريبه من سلطنه عمان اصبح
هناك ايضا اقبال كبير من السياح
والمشجعين كاس العالم لحضور لهذا الكاس
طبعا نشاهد الان هذه احد اشهر المحلات
موجوده هنا محل لبيع البان مساء الخير او
صباح الخير
حسين المهدي حسين ايش تبيع في المحل هنا
ببيع بخور والباب طيب البان الان كيف
طريقه التعامل مع يتاكل والعبور نقع في
المويه ايش الطريقه لا وجه الطريقه
[موسيقى]
كم تقريبا السعر الكيلو الكيلو الانسان من
35 و25 الى 150 درهم اماراتي تقريبا 100$
امريكي طيب يعطيك العافيه شكرا جزيلا يعني
شفتوا هذا المحل العريق يمكن ربما عمره
يتجاوز المئه عام لكن حقيقه البضائع جميله
سهام ونادين والتفاصيل جميله والاسعار
ايضا مناسبه لان السوق شعبي فالاسعار في
متناول اليد
فقط
بدنا نشير عبد الرحمن نظرا لاهميه هذا
السوق التاريخ الرابط بين الماضي والحاضر
حتى قصائد الحب في الزمن العماني القديم
كتبت في هذا السوق يعني قصائد حب الى سوق
مطرح
صحيح والجميل ايضا نادين انه كثير من
المحلات هنا متوارثه من الاجداد الى
الابناء يعني صاحب المحل هنا في هذا السوق
لا يفرط في المحل بتاتا حتى لو احيانا
تعرض مثلا الاقتصاد الى بعض الضرر جراء
مثلا جاء احد يذكرون قبل سنتين او بعض
الركود لكن الجميع لا يفرط في هذه المحلات
وتتورث من الاجداد الى الابناء شاهدت اكثر
من شخص عماني يصير ايضا انه يبيع في المحل
زي ما شفنا قبل شوي حسين يعني هو شاب
عماني لكن يبيع ويشتري في المحلات هنا وفي
اصاله واراقه في المكان وحقيقه سلطنه عمان
هذا ما يميزها يميز شعبها انه راغب
الحداثه ورغم متطور اللي موجود لكن همم
الاصاله متمسكين فيها حتى المباني المباني
مثلا الوزاريه المباني الحكوميه يجب ان
يكون تصميم هذه المباني على الطراز
العماني الاصيل ف- اا عندهم مزيج رائع
صراحه وجميل
الاقمشه صراحه رافت انتباهي هنا الاقمشه
الكشميريه الاقمشه الجميله
عبد الرحمن طيب نادين رومانسيه حكت على
القصائد انا واقعيه شو بدك تجيب لنا من
السوق انت كل منطقه تجيب لنا شغله
من الاخر على فكره صار وعدنا بكثير
والشنطه عن كل ما بتكبروا ما شفنا ولا شيء
شكرا جزيلا عبد الرحمن